today's topic shannon Lester guys I
actually had to delete the original
video just because it emitted some
important information so I'm redoing it
based off some of the research I did I
believe that Shaolin may be lying about
the whole story right and it seems
disingenuous for us to react to that
story and have our take on it when it
may be based on completely on a
fabricated story so I will present those
ideas for you you can take it how you
want whatever you want and then you'll
also see me and preaches reaction to the
original story now we've covered two
videos on Shaolin she's one of those
youtubers that has some of the worst
takes I've ever seen on some topics on
other topics she's got pretty decent
takes but she got exposed vote did you
see the video that the guy did no I
think it's DeAngelo Wallace oh yeah I
was saying a bunch of a bunch of lies
about him right exactly yeah he got the
receipts and stuff like that yeah so she
got exposed for basically making up
stuff about celebrities on her videos
claiming she had inside sources but
things that could be easily disproven
with online Google searches here's some
things that I know about Ellen she is so
mean to that why for her what Ellen did
to her allegedly allegedly that was
always so bad was that she refused to
let this woman have a baby but the issue
with that is that's just flat-out wrong
like when she said it didn't sound like
a real thing to me so I did a bit of
research not only did I find this clip
from Ellen explaining that her wife
Portia doesn't want kids no Portia don't
want kids she doesn't like the squealing
when they're in a pool that that
high-pitched squealing of joy that they
have I also found this quote from Portia
herself an out magazine saying you have
to really want to have kids and neither
of us did so it's just gonna be me and
Ellen and no babies but were the best of
friends and married life is blissful it
really is I've never been happier than I
am right now
here's the thing we didn't want to cover
it anymore because I thought the other
do youtubers did such a good job they
did not so what ended up happening was
that she put out a video recently yeah
and I want you to watch this okay okay
hey showers so today we have to talk
about something a little different I am
being extorted stop she's going bad
I've never seen Challen without makeup
this is what you do when you know you're
gonna cry
yes I'm about to put on a performance
let me see if my UK fellas
here comes to other webs a woman named
Swati Shukla she is someone I considered
a very close friend she runs the
whatsapp the showers whatsapp group and
we were gonna go into business together
in a different venture and I woke up
today
to a message saying these other
youtubers are offering me money to sell
our private whatsapp chats and I'm going
to do it I just want you to know to
create more contrary controversy because
your views are down 80% who you've been
hitting a real hard let's listen more to
what this Michael Jackson bad yeah Mike
Tyson back when I was like my most
vulnerable and that's a really hard
thing to think you know like you can
have like strangers on the other day who
cares like who even cares but like when
you have someone that you've shared
things with and they you think that you
were just like a mark to them
I I just really wouldn't wish that on
anyone like betrayal is it's hey let me
read a titled evil week how to destroy
your enemies conflict resolution from
the art of war evil week dating advice
how did she do and not get puck you guys
are tired of getting manipulated I hear
it all the time you're tired of getting
cheated on so is the answer to become
the thing you fear and hate the most a
cheater Academy
evil week how to manipulate your boss
and co-workers to get ahead at work the
way you manipulate anyone is to find
their weakness identify their shadow
self and press ok we act like men are
complicated they're not they're shitty
and they lie
betrayal and manipulation hurts mmm
imagine teaching people how to cheat and
how to manipulate their partners imagine
teaching people how to manipulate their
employees their fellow co-workers and
their bosses in order to get raises to
get ahead imagine doing a whole series
of YouTube videos on how to be a bad
person and then being surprised when
people use those exact same techniques
on you people want to test me what do
you guys said the other day I don't know
who would watch your channel Shaolin and
think that's the girl I want to pick a
fight with and you know what she was
right that's a smart woman a stupid
woman thinks the opposite a stupid woman
says oh Shaolin looks weak or is
strategy and now I just look back I'm
like was she just buttering me up you
know like was she preying on me when I
was like at my most vulnerable or is
patience and if you knock on the devil's
door long enough someone is going to
answer you and you won't like what's on
the other side of that door
I just really wouldn't wish that on
anyone like betrayal is
now I recognize that extortions bad I
would never encourage an army I want
including Shaolin but it does make me
feel a little bit less bad when someone
teaches people how to scam and then gets
mad when they get scammed am I crazy my
[ __ ] brother this is the game that you
thought now you want to play the game to
this moment but now I'm a Buddhist monk
let me tell you crazy she goes on crying
during this video you are no longer on
higher ground the students surpass their
master boo boo honey chicken cherry
child are you saying that she's anakin
to Obi one yes you got played by your
own goddamn game I mean listen you
thought you were playing Mario Kart but
your controller was not even plugged in
they played you like a fiddle
dude it's over and I'm not excited
because I see you down like that I
wouldn't wish that on that but that's
what you prone you put out there yes and
you got smack back cheese yeah you're
mad that she lied to you and
misrepresented their relationship bubu
you've lied about so many celebrities as
if they weren't human beings you've
literally made up facts I'm not saying
you got things wrong you have
purposefully and intentionally made up
facts about people and then
misrepresented them and haven't
apologized and retracted those things so
how am I supposed to feel bad for
someone who continuously lies who
teaches people how to scam who teaches
people how to cheat and then when they
games bad situation they want to get on
YouTube cry and think they're going to
get my sympathy or anyone else's and her
fans are eating her alive
have you checked her reddit it is one of
the greatest things ever her reddit is
van Anna's it got so bad that they've
had to ban people for calling her out so
much so what I would say in this
situation is this three people how you
want to be treated put out into the
world what you want to return to you
generally speaking what we do is
for accountability and we ask people to
be decent human beings to each other
unfortunately showered some of the
messages that you've put out has been
extremely negative and you haven't taken
it accountability for that no we've and
we've retracted those things in
apologize surely right what up dojo
yes yeah back at you okay the people
that you're gonna stone on your way up
you're gonna have to face them on your
way down the boom and that's exactly
what you're doing right now what's
happening you're facing the music it
sucks I know but if it's self-inflicted
that's right and so your YouTube
channels is plummeting and you hide your
subscriber count because you don't want
people to see just how bad you're being
hurt right now but you are and you could
say all this talk about how you're like
I got other revenue seems and doesn't
hurt me seeing you cry on your YouTube
video Google no makeup on barely a
shower yeah this would never be a video
I would cover normally but just knowing
your history and things that you've said
I just find it very ironic that you
haven't addressed that yet you want to
be sympathize with who miss me with that
bull take all your yeah yeah maybe you
should be teaching things to people that
you are not applying yourself so at one
point when she's telling the story she
talks about how she gave swathi $1400 as
a way to help her provides a screenshot
of the transaction now at face value
it looks very legit right you look at
the the screenshot it looks right so
then I compared it to my phone I have an
Android so when I send someone money it
looked different some of the words were
slightly different but I'm like it's on
an Android so maybe it's a problem with
me so I borrowed my roommates iPhone and
then I downloaded the app and then I
went into my account and I did the exact
same thing and lo and behold now it
looks identical but still some of the
words are different if you notice and
doesn't say you paid $1400 it says you
sent meaning when you send someone money
and right if you look at the transaction
type at the bottom it says money sent
that's why it says you sent one dollar
and 89 cents to blank but on Shannon's a
screenshot you notice it says you paid
and that struck me as a little bit odd
because I used to run an online
store normally you paid is when you
basically are paying out invoices and
stuff like that or you're paying stores
for transactions then it you only use
you pay that's what it least struck me I
saw I pulled it up and I pulled up one
of my old transactions I did I think
with uber look at the difference now you
says you've paid right so now you're
seeing the word paid but it's no longer
money set it's a different type of
transaction that you're engaging and
hence the words are different the second
thing that I think stands out to me the
most is it says from Washington Mutual
now I looked up Washington Mutual but
Washington Mutual has been closed since
2008 I'm assuming due to the recession
they went under but as a bank they no
longer exist and they haven't existed in
years yeah it's all written in small
letters I don't know why there are no
caps on it at all normally for a proper
name or when you're naming a company
your first letters always in large
letters I don't know as you guys know
after DeAngelo Wallace exposed or
Shaolin decided that she was going to
hide her subscribers
hide the like to dislike Rachel on all
her videos why are you hiding your subs
and Shaolin replies because my subs are
being harassed a large chunk of my
audience is under 18 and actually
sniping teenagers off one by one
commenting hey I hope you get deleted
because you like Shaolin is it really ok
with me I'm protecting my girls that's
what that's what a pack leader does I
don't think at any point during my time
on YouTube have I ever clicked on the
sub count to go see who subscribed to
them I don't think you're allowed to
that's not even a feature that exists so
if you're trying to protect your viewers
how does it help them or to hide the one
functionality that doesn't showcase
their identity in any type of way I had
went her money I lied her a lot of money
I lent her $1400
you know when you do something and you
like don't want to tell your friends cuz
you know that they're gonna be like what
did you do like and it's not because
your friends are being judgmental it's
because they represent what you already
know they're the Greek chorus and she
gave me this story about you know it's
the pandemic she's she lives in India
and but lives in like a 20 bedroom house
has servants would complain when her
servants didn't show up and she had to
wash her own breakfast spoon like she's
not she the president of your fan club
is a lawyer who has a whole bunch of
employees that work under her and is
also from a super wealthy rich family
and somehow she needs your money but she
also has enough time to run your fan
club but also as a full-time lawyer she
can manage all those employees but she's
like my law firm is basically dead in
the water
i drained my savings paying my employees
I need $1,400 to make payroll and I was
she's like they're all women and I'm
like I just can't like it is stupid that
is one of the dumbest stories and the
fact that it came from someone from
India makes it even funnier next we're
gonna tell me that you were done in by a
Nigerian prince at some point this story
sounds so ridiculous is enough she was
just like she couldn't have tried to
make up a lie that's stupid but this
does sound really dumb doesn't it
like I'm not the only one who's
listening to this and like this is
really unbelievable you tell me that you
lent 40 hundred fourteen hundred dollars
to a stranger you've never met there's
no legal action you can take against me
I'm not an American
I also think there's a chance you could
save your reputation and you should be
given that how merciful mm-hmm you have
24 hours to PayPal me the money and give
me in written writing that you have
waived off the loan the $1,400 loan 24
hours or I walk let me get this straight
the scammer says you can't do anything
to me about me extorting you because I'm
not a American citizen so you might as
well comply but then this camera also
says I need you to forgive this $1400
loan why if they can't extort you why
would you think that you can recoup the
$1400 like what even if she was an
American citizen like recouping $1,400
is extremely difficult you ever taken
someone to small claims court it's very
expensive and it's time-consuming that's
why most of the time people don't like
going to court over small sums this is
really weird why would she want a
written piece of paper saying that
you're gonna forgive the 1400 loan but
she's gonna extort you and she's not
worried about consequences does that
make sense to y'all all right it's
making my head hurt because I'm like am
I the stupid one this or is this story
really ridiculous now look I'm not here
saying that
Chauncey's not a real person from the
research I've done she is or her account
was real and that she interacted with a
lot of different people that's all we
really know I just want to bring this to
your attention I'm not saying whether or
not the enjoys true or false I'm just
saying there's a lot of hints at it that
is probably not nearly as true she
claims and based off of past history to
lie about people to omit and make up
facts out of nowhere it's hard for
anybody to give her the benefit of the
doubt you feel what I'm saying and it
seems like because her YouTube channel
was taking such a nosedive and it was
you could actually look this up on
social blade her views were down almost
75 percent from last month it seemed
like this was a video she did to spike
things back up she thought this was
gonna shoot her back up into the big
game and the reality is it didn't work
she spiked up very fast for that video
and everything went back to normal so
what do you want me to say I want you
guys to get the full context so there
you have it
and hopefully this paints a good picture
for you guys what we want to talk about
what's the name of the wonderful
youtuber that first called out
D'Angelo Wallace D'Angelo what shout
outs to you my dude yeah shout out for
you yeah so that's it for today's video
we put this out because we wanted people
to know about this I don't if I feel bad
for her yeah why would I at all not a
bit it's bad what happens I wouldn't
wish that on someone but that is a thing
all right I wouldn't wish certain things
to some people but if that's your core
and what you believe in which you go by
then it happens to you that's what you
believe in so why would I feel bad
yeah the people you teve with yeah
people you did that is that you and some
other people too you instruct the masses
that toxic behavior how to replicate
that toxic behavior how to do this toxic
pattern and then when it happens to you
here's how you delete someone and then
you get deleted to me that's what
happened so I don't feel bad if ik like
I don't feel bad if a gangbanger against
game yeah
[Music]